like oh we're having fun right when the
thing oh slip oh and this that's why you
see this kind of why you don't have
shower sex sexy sure yeah that is some
sexy sex but yo danger who are you that
you need that kind of risk in your life
shower sex it's debatable
I'm for shower sex because I'm a man of
reason [ __ ] all you want just don't do
it in the shower if you're into
adventure and you're not lazy then you
should have sex in the shower I say no
to shower sex roll up and [ __ ] in the
shower the shower is for cleaning not
for [ __ ] you're gonna die when you're
in a relationship you want to switch it
up you can't just have sex in the
missionary position every single
question it gets boring as sheets are
not in the way you have unfettered
access to all of the body any human body
covered in water is gorgeous like
[ __ ] gorgeous you can't really
compare that to anything having sex in
the shower is great not only do you get
clean but you get real dirty everything
sounds better in the bathroom it's great
acoustics guttural sounds now they sound
like choirs of angels the sound of an
angel
intimacy you're in there it's steamy
water on each other you're just oh
that's another thing having sex in the
shower you're clean and you don't have
to worry about yes yes baby it's sex but
sex whatever type of sexy one I have in
the shower you can make sure it's clean
that's something that a lot of people
are worried about it I'm not saying a
cold shower you can take a lukewarm
shower the passion will warm up the
water
this is another situation okay you live
with your parents you don't wanna know
what your parents did in there or what
they got in there live with the
roommates I can't really wanna know
what's in there I take showers to have
my alone time and that's where I have my
best thoughts you know when I want I
want that shower to be my time shower
sex is dangerous yeah oh no no no fun
way you could slip and crack your
[ __ ] head open way water is the worst
lubricant of all time and then what's
the second thing they'll just put soap
on their deck and that my friends is a
call from yeast infections bodily fluids
plus water changes how those fluids work
they don't work the more water you have
the more the less slippery becomes the
more more friction the last thing I want
to do is put an activity that's gonna
take between two minutes and two hours
if I'm gonna use the water to my
advantage I also have to accept that
it's to my disadvantage and that water
plus sweet oh and natural lubrication
it's bad it doesn't work I'm not saying
you having sex in the shower everyday
like every time the water comes on it's
BoneTown 2016 it's not everyone be sure
to check out Ryan's first most showers
for young young people are barely built
for one person I know you share it's the
same thing with the goddamn Titanic two
people can go on you can do a Captain
Morgan unlike the soap holder brilliant
great idea put your foot on this soap
it's like wet twister you figure it out
that's hard assess as well yeah I'll be
the girl you guys show me what is the
position yes again well I mean shower
sex position you you know you just go
and just you know you're fine have you
had sex in the show I have attempted it
it didn't work and there's a terrible
experience I can Yelp the experience and
give it one star a condom will break
with whatever luck with the lubrication
if you add water to it you're adding
friction that it doesn't want they can
only handle so much friction
especially this trusted strawberry how
you how is this not gonna slip off when
you got water everywhere but I can save
sex people it's not that dangerous she's
a liar it's dangerous okay but now one
of us is wet and the other one is it you
have the shower on you
you're back and I'm dry tangle cold I'm
cold
I didn't feel strongly about it until I
thought it through like more and I'm
like yeah no I don't want that [ __ ]
outside the shower alright
don't [ __ ] it if you're very vanilla
and don't want to try shower sex then
you know just keep having sex in your
own bed I think you can have sex in many
places and shower is one of the many
places if I could have sex every time I
took a shower I'm totally that would be
really dirty
always
sound of the water oh honey